tell me I'm not gonna make it I told him
you crazy
my name is exotic I get foreign checks
when they pay me Travis Barker's
daughter Alabama has a message for
haters of her new music all three of
them have tortured me since I was like
they were like two years old
so it's kind of all they know the 17
year old continues to follow in her
dad's musical footsteps and teased a new
unreleased rap track he told me I'm not
gonna make it I told him you crazy
when they pay me
I got it engraved in the master
congrassing the payment record labels
telling me I'm the greatest
I did write this all by myself in my
room the new track seems to have gotten
mixed reactions with some criticizing
her for rapping about overcoming
struggles while she grew up in a famous
family but Alabama's brushing it off and
even posted the song again you tell me
I'm not gonna make it I told him you
crazy one fan writes in the comments
y'all are mad it's actually good go off
sis Alabama responding I swear to God I
don't care what they think another Tick
Tock user writes that money doesn't
equal a successful music career and she
has to work for it something Alabama
agreed with
so yeah they've they've all played music
from a really young age and kind of been
around the industry and kind of seen
like they've seen the the Glamorous side
of it and then how much you have to work
and and rehearse and so I've made sure
to make them well-rounded seeing like
everything it takes to get where I am
and uh and then all the stuff you get to
enjoy Alabama's been dropping music
since she was 11 years old releasing her
debut single our house in 2017.
what was the inspiration behind the song
I I'm a homebody yeah so I just want to
do something about home I just thought
of some cool ideas and we put it in her
brother Landon has the music bug too
he's also an aspiring musician
[Music]
the siblings have full support from both
parents including mom actress and model
Shayna Moakler Travis's ex-wife I'm
really proud of each one for all the
different creative Outlets that they're
they're doing you know so I'm excited to
see them in the future and and what they
bring to the table Yeah so there's no
doubt we'll be seeing more music coming
from the Barker fam you told me I'm not
gonna make it I told him you crazy my
name is exotic I get foreign checks when
they pay me I got it engraved in the
master Congress telling me I'm the
greatest